Prof: Okay,
I think I should begin.
So we're at the point in the
course now where we're talking
about the Capital Asset Pricing
Model and the economists'
understanding of risk aversion
and its consequence for the
financial sector.
So much of what economists know
was already known to
businessmen,
because it's common sense,
and even to literary writers
like Shakespeare,
who was himself quite a
successful businessman.
So you might remember that
Shakespeare already had the idea
of diversification.
In the Merchant of Venice,
Antonio says "Each boat on
a different ocean."
He said it a bit more
poetically than that,
"each sail on a different
argosy" or something.
I've forgotten what it was,
but each boat on a different
ocean.
So he wasn't very worried
because he was diversified.
He also had the idea of risk
and return.
Nothing ventured,
nothing gained.
so ventured means risk.
Nothing gained.
So another way of saying this
diversification is "Don't
put all your eggs in one
basket."
So what have economists done
that wasn't already known to
every business person and every
clever literary writer?
Well, economists have
quantified this and turned this
into a usable,
practical piece of advice.
So the diversification theorem
in CAPM-- so I should have moved
CAPM.
I should have called this
Shakespeare and this CAPM.
CAPM becomes the mutual fund
theorem.
So the mutual fund theorem has
very practical advice.
It says if you're investing in
the stock market,
don't try to pick out
individual stocks.
Hold every stock in proportion
to its value in the whole
economy.
If you want to be more
venturesome, don't pick riskier
stocks.
Just simply leave less money in
the bank.
So divide all your money
between the index and the bank.
It says, hold all your money in
stocks in the same proportion
everyone else is holding them.
Hold the market, in other words.
Hold an index like the S&P
500, of all the stocks,
in proportion to how big they
are.
And if you want to get more
venturesome--if you're cautious,
put some of your money in the
index and some of it in the
bank.
If you want to be more
venturesome, take some money out
of the bank and put it into the
stocks.
But in the index.
If you want to be even more
venturesome than that,
borrow the money to put the
money into the stock market.
That's called leverage.
But you should,
according to this theory,
not try to pick stocks.
So if you're interested in
risk, you shouldn't pick high
technology startup companies.
You should pick the same
mixture of blue chip companies
like General Electric and these
startup companies that everybody
else is choosing.
So that's what it means to
diversify.
Hold a little bit of everything
in the same proportion as
everyone else.
So it's much more precise,
much more surprising than
Shakespeare's advice.
Then the second thing,
risk and reward,
it says that the price of a
security,
so we'll call it pi_J
say,
which we used to think of as
the expectation--
of course, you need the
probabilities--
of the payoff of the security
J, discounted.
That's what we would have
thought the price was.
So this is called the
covariance pricing theorem.
The shocking thing is,
it's not the expectation
discounted, which is what we
thought it was before.
We know that you have to adjust
for risk somehow,
which we haven't taken into
account before.
But what's so shocking is,
you might have thought you'd
subtract maybe something times
the variance of the return of
asset J,
but that's not going to be the
case.
It's going to be,
surprisingly,
subtracting something times the
covariance, with the market,
of asset J.
So you penalize--the price of a
stock should go lower if it gets
riskier.
Its risk is not defined by what
its variance is,
but by what its covariance is
with the market.
So I want to develop these two
ideas in this lecture,
spend the whole lecture on just
developing these two ideas,
which are the modern
mathematical version of what
Shakespeare already knew 400
years ago,
but made much more concrete,
much more precise,
with the mathematics wholly
behind them.
So what have we got here?
We imagine a world,
the situation I'm going to
describe, is the one we had last
time, where we know that there
are different things that can
happen.
These are the states with
different probabilities,
so there's states.
s = 1 to big S and each of them
have probabilities,
with probabilities
gamma_s.
Of course, the sum of the
gamma_s = 1.
So everybody knows the
probabilities of the states and
then they know what the payoff
is of the different assets.
So here's A^(1), here's A^(2),
here's A^(J) say,
and they know what the payoffs
are going to be,
A^(1) in state 1,
A^(1) in state 2,
A^(1) in state S,
A^(2) in state 1,
A^(2) in state S,
A^(J) in state 1,
A^(J) in state 2,
A^(J) in state S.
So given these probabilities
and given the payoffs,
you can compute the expectation
of each thing.
You can compute the expectation
of A^(J), say.
It's just the summation from s
= 1 to S of gamma_s
A^(J)_s.
You can also compute the
variance, so I'll write that
sometimes as A bar^(J).
You can compute the variance of
A^(J),
which is the summation,
s = 1 to S,
remember, of gamma_s
A^(J)_s - A bar^(j)
squared.
Okay, and you could also
compute the covariance of any 2,
A^(J) and A^(K) as summation
gamma_s
A^(J)_s - A bar^(J)
times (this is s = 1 to S) of
A^(K)_s - A bar^(K) K.
So those three numbers,
the expectation,
the variance and the covariance
between any pairs,
those are numbers that anybody
could compute,
knowing the payoffs of the
assets and knowing the
probabilities.
And what the theory is going to
say,
the capital asset pricing
model, that model is going to
explain how the prices of all
the assets depend on their
expectation,
their variances and their
covariances,
under the assumption that
people have quadratic utilities,
or more generally,
assume people only care about
the mean--
that's the expectation--and
variance of final consumption.
So we wrote that last time.
We said if you had quadratic
utility for consumption in every
state,
you could summarize these
thousands--
there could be millions of
states and thousands of
securities.
You add them all together,
what you hold,
it only depends on the end
about what the expectation and
the variance of your final
portfolio is.
You like expectation and you
hate variance.
So under that hypothesis,
we're going to have a very
concrete interpretation of what
Shakespeare was talking about
from the beginning,
which is going to allow us to
quantify what you should do,
how people in the market are
doing.
We'll be able to answer a
series of questions.
And then we'll be able to test
the theory too.
So now the theory I'm about to
explain was developed in 1950.
It began in 1950 when Koopmans
was a professor at the Cowles
Foundation, the director of the
Cowles Foundation,
was in Chicago.
I told you, the Cowles
Foundation was started by Alfred
Cowles,
who'd been a Yale
undergraduate,
and his family owned the
Chicago Tribune and a
bunch of other newspapers.
And he ran a macroeconomic
forecasting company in 1929,
right after the crash.
He was embarrassed to realize
that he had predicted that
everything was going to be fine,
and he sent around
questionnaires and read
everybody else's,
his competitors' newspapers,
and realized they'd been
predicting everything was going
to be fine too,
except for one guy,
Jones, the Dow Jones guy.
Except for that,
everybody had been making the
same rosy predictions.
So he decided the whole subject
of economic forecasting,
in fact, economics altogether
was a fraud,
and he wanted to put money in
encouraging the use of
mathematics in economics,
instead of the touchy-feely
more qualitative analysis that
was the norm at the time.
So he went to see Irving
Fisher, who was the great Yale
economist, and said,
"What should I do with all
the money?
Where should I put this
institute, and who should I
invite to the institute?"
So Fisher and he set up the
whole thing and it started in
Colorado Springs,
because Fisher believed in
fresh air,
and he wrote a lot of books
about fresh air and how it
staved off tuberculosis and
things like that.
And no one wanted to go to
Colorado Springs,
so they moved it to Chicago
where the family was originally
from, the Cowles family.
The director then in the '50s
was someone named Koopmans,
and Koopmans had this idea of
trying to examine risk by making
people with quadratic utilities.
And he said,
"Okay, student Markowitz,
why don't you try to develop a
theory?"
And Markowitz began the theory
of the capital asset pricing
model.
Now the theory,
just to get a little ahead of
the story,
Markowitz went quite a ways,
won a Nobel prize many years
later for what he did,
but didn't quite get to the end.
And while he was working on it,
Koopmans didn't want to be
director any more of Cowles,
and he invited Tobin,
the great Yale economist,
to come and be director of
Cowles.
And Tobin got there and the
people at the University of
Chicago said to Tobin,
"Well, we're glad you're
coming.
You'll be right next to us,
but don't try and get us mixed
up with all those mathematical
people at the Cowles Foundation.
They're all crazy.
We would like to keep that high
tech mathematics out of our
department.
That's just Cowles' crazy
idea."
So Tobin refused the job,
came back to Yale,
and Markowitz was so angry--not
Markowitz.
Koopmans, his advisor,
was so angry that he went to
Cowles and said,
"They're not treating us
right at the University of
Chicago.
Let's move the entire Cowles
Foundation to Yale."
So in 1955, they moved it to
Yale.
But in these conversations
Tobin had with Koopmans and the
Cowles Foundation,
he got to know what Markowitz
was doing,
and so he added the final
crowning achievement to--
the mutual fund theorem--to the
Markowitz setup,
and he subsequently won the
Nobel Prize for that.
In fact, the New York
Times said in its
description of what he won the
Nobel Prize for,
the New York Times
said, "James Tobin won the
Nobel prize for showing that you
shouldn't put all your eggs in
one basket."
So anyway, that's the theory
that I have to explain now,
that it's a little bit less
trivial than just saying,
"Don't put all your eggs
in one basket.
So, the idea is that you like
expectation, you hate variance.
So the first thing we're going
to do is notice that
covariance--I'm sorry,
standard deviation is defined
as the square root of variance.
So to say that you don't like
variance means you don't like
standard deviation.
They're the same thing,
but you're going to see,
it makes the diagrams much
prettier.
So if we had a portfolio that
you could choose among some
combination of putting your
money in the A's,
you'd get some expectation of
some standard deviation for your
total portfolio.
And people like more
expectation and like less
standard deviation.
So the indifference curves are
going in that direction,
unlike the usual picture.
That was the first step.
Now the first thing we noticed
last time, this was three weeks
ago or so, we made an extremely
important observation.
We said, what is the covariance
of part of your money in X,
the variance of part of your
money in X and the rest of your
money--
let's say you have 1 dollar--so
t in X and (1 - t) in Y?
For example,
1 half in X and 1 half in Y.
Well that is by definition the
same as the covariance of this
portfolio with itself,
and now we know this from this
theorem,
from this definition of
covariance,
that if you look at the
covariance of J with K,
so fixing K--this is just
linear.
This is a constant,
multiplying the differences
from J and its expectation.
So this is a linear in each
variable,
so therefore this is going to
equal the covariance of tX with
tX twice the covariance of t--
so the covariance of tX and (1
- t)Y,
the covariance of (1 - t)Y and
tX (1 - t) squared (so I'll put
that one over here) the
covariance of (1 - tY) with
itself.
So I've taken this with this,
then this with that,
then that with that and that
with the thing on the end.
But it's linear again,
so I can pull out all these
things.
So that's the formula.
Now what we noticed is that if
2 stocks, X and Y,
are independent,
their covariance is 0.
So I'm assuming you remember
that, so those terms just go
away.
And then it's also linear,
so this is just going to equal
t squared, covariance of X with
X, which is just the variance of
X.
So assume XY independent,
then that is what allows me to
cancel these two terms like
that.
So I get t squared times the
covariance of X (1 - t) squared
times the variance of Y.
If I take t = 1 half,
I know that the variance of 1
half X 1 half Y = 1 quarter
times the variance of X 1
quarter times the variance of Y.
We derived this three weeks ago.
I'm just repeating it.
So the amazing thing is,
if X and Y have the same
expectation and the same
variance,
but are independent of each
other, by splitting your money
between two independent things,
you're obviously going to have
the same expectation,
but only half the variance.
And that last step is,
the variance of X = variance of
Y.
So amazingly--or it's not so
amazing, I guess,
if you've thought about it--but
if you haven't thought about it,
you've got 2 equal risks.
Neither one is better than the
other, so why bother with one
rather than the other?
They're both the same.
But if they're independent,
you should put half your money
in each of them.
You get the same expectation,
but you're going to get only
half the variance.
So if you have 2 dice,
let's say the first die will
give you--you pay 100 dollars
for a dice, you can get 100 the
number of dots showing.
So if it gets a 1 that's 101
dollars, you get a 6,
it's 106 dollars.
So if you held 1 dice,
1 die, you'd get on average 103
and 1 half dollars.
You could pay 100,
get 1 die, which on average
paid 103 and 1 half.
Instead, you could put 50
dollars in the first die,
get half of that,
50 dollars in the second die,
get half of that.
So on average,
you're still getting 103 and 1
half, but the variance you get
is going to be half of what it
was before.
So in this picture,
you start off with X and Y with
the same standard deviation and
the same expectation,
but they're independent and now
you put half your money in each
and you cut the variance in
half,
which means you divide--the
standard deviation is the square
root--
so you divide it by the square
root of 2.
So you've improved.
You've moved to the left.
You've gotten less standard
deviation without constricting
your expectation at all.
So that's the most important
thing to notice.
I'm going to say one more
thing, one more way.
I'm going to go back to this
formula, which is where the
variance was,
here.
Now suppose--let's look at that
formula.
Suppose I take 2 stocks,
which I'm going to switch now,
X and Y.
That was most unfortunate.
But suppose I take 2 stocks and
I'm at the point where all my
money is in Y.
So I'm going to take the case t
= 0.
So if I took t = 0,
I would just have the variance
of Y.
That's actually quite good,
the variance of Y.
So I'd have all my money in Y.
I'd have this standard
deviation and this expectation.
Now what happens if the two are
independent, X and Y?
Let's drop the fact that they
have the same variance now.
Maybe X has way more variance
than Y does.
So look, X is much riskier than
Y.
Maybe X has a higher
expectation than Y,
but it's so risky.
People who are risk averse
wouldn't ever want to subject
themselves to all this risk,
say.
So maybe they should just stick
with Y, you would think.
But no, the answer is,
you shouldn't,
because what happens if you
start to mix some of your money
in Y--
take a little out of Y and put
a little bit into X?
Your expectation,
if you take a little money out
of Y and put a little into X,
your expectation's going to go
up, because it's going to be the
average of X and Y.
So the expectation's going up.
But then you say,
"Oh, but my variance is
going up."
So I wouldn't want to do it,
but no, that's wrong.
The variance isn't going up,
because they're independent.
Even though X has a way higher
variance than Y,
mixing a little between the two
lowers your variance.
So how could that be?
Seems quite shocking.
Well, let's take the derivative
of this with respect to having
all your money originally in Y.
So this is the variance of
putting t dollars in X and 1 - t
in Y.
So we simply take the
derivative of that,
which I've done here,
I suppose.
Why don't I just write it out?
Take the derivative of that,
d/dt of this = 2t times the
variance of X 2 times (1 - t)
times (okay,
but this is a -,
so I take the derivative) it's
2 times this times - 1,
so - 2T, 2 times (1 - t),
variance of Y.
Let's evaluate that at t = 0.
The first term is 0,
the t is 0, so this doesn't
matter.
The second term,
t is 0, so this is - 2 times
the variance of Y.
It's going down.
The variance is actually going
down here.
So just as this says,
the variance starts down.
Eventually, it has to end up
here, so as you move your money,
all of it originally in Y and
start moving some of it into X,
your variance is going to go
down.
So those two things put
together are the argument for
diversification.
If they're independent and
identical, then you should put
half your money in each.
But even if they're not
identical, you shouldn't stick
to Y.
You should mix Y with some X.
So there's why diversification
is such a good idea.
So it's not all diversification.
It's diversification of
independent risks.
There's a bit of a mathematical
nuance.
Diversification of independent
risks is bound to help you.
Everybody should diversify a
little bit, because you can
reduce your risk.
That's the first important
thought.
Now I don't want to do too much
in the mathematics.
So I prove in the notes,
but I won't do it here,
suppose we didn't assume X and
Y were independent.
Suppose X and Y were
arbitrarily chosen.
They have big covariance,
whatever you want.
Then what is going to happen
when you combine your money
between X and Y.
So there's a proof,
which I'm not going to give,
because I'm a little bit
behind, so the proof is this.
Suppose we have exactly the
same situation,
where you started with Y and
you've got X,
and you could think of moving
you money in between X and Y.
Well, it turns out,
if they're perfectly
correlated,
so really they're the same
thing, Y is just 80 percent of
X,
it's the same stock,
so moving back between them is
not really changing--
X is just a scalar improvement
on Y,
so it has more expectation and
more standard deviation.
If that were the case,
you'd just move on that
straight line that connects the
two points.
I must have a way of doing this.
Yes, if they were perfectly
correlated, you would just be
moving along this line by
putting your money in between.
If they're independent,
you're going to move along that
line.
But no matter how correlated
they are,
as long as they're not
perfectly correlated,
it's going to turn out the
curve you get by moving between
them is going to look like that.
If they're negatively
correlated, then you can really
improve yourself and get a curve
that looks like that.
Independent will be like this,
positively correlated,
but not perfectly will be like
that,
and perfectly positively
correlated,
no diversification gains,
you get the straight line,
but you're always above the
straight line.
So that's a kind of--anyway,
it takes a little bit of
algebra to prove that,
you know, the Cauchy-Schwarz
inequality, but I'm going to
skip that.
But anyway, that's a
mathematical fact.
You see in the independent
case, we proved that the line
has to start going that way and
eventually it has to end up
here,
so it should be no surprise
that it looks like that in the
independent case.
And then it turns out that
every other case is sort of in
between that or at the other
extreme.
It always has this bowed out
shape.
So there's always gains to
diversification,
something you're getting out of
diversification.
The risk is somehow going down
by mixing things up.
That's it, that's the
mathematics and that's the
general principle.
Now, what can you get out of
this?
I want to derive these two
famous theorems,
which we already saw in action
in the example that we
calculated, but it seemed like a
miracle.
So what did we find in the
example we calculated last time
in class?
We found that--we only had two
stocks,
but if there had been hundreds
of stocks and millions of states
of nature,
and each person had a different
utility,
different risk aversion,
but all quadratic,
and you calculated the
competitive equilibrium,
assuming there were Arrow
securities,
it would end up that every
consumer held the same mix of
all these stocks,
positive or negative amounts of
the bond.
So the mutual fund theorem
turned out to be true,
that the best thing everybody
could do was hold the same
amount,
the same proportion of stocks
and bonds,
and maybe more or less of the
riskless asset,
maybe even negative of the
riskless asset.
So I want to show you why
that's true now.
Then we're going to have to
talk about whether we really
believe it or not.
So let's see what an
implication is.
Suppose now what I do is I
write down--I have all these
stocks, X, Y and Z.
So you can imagine--you have a
certain amount of money--so you
can imagine putting your
money--so let's suppose that
I've written down all the
stocks.
The prices are given.
Let's say prices of stocks are
in equilibrium.
So I've solved for the
equilibrium like we did last
time, and I write down X,
Q, Y and Z.
These are the expectation and
standard deviation per dollar of
the stocks, or per I dollars of
the stock.
Maybe the person has exactly I
dollars, so let's say it's I
dollars of each stock,
what their expectation,
return and standard deviation
would be.
If 1 dollar,
you get some expectation,
standard deviation,
10 dollars of the same stock,
you'd be able to buy 10 shares,
which means you would--
10 times as many shares,
which means you'd have 10 times
the expectation and 10 times the
standard deviation.
So whatever the guy's income
is, they'll fix the returns as
per his income,
because he's going to spend all
his income on these stocks.
So what could he do?
He could put all his money into
X, he'd end up here,
or all his money into Y,
he'd end up here,
or all his money into Z,
and he'd end up here.
But maybe he wants to divide
part of his money in Y,
part in Z and part in Y.
He'll be somewhere like here.
Or maybe he wants to instead
put part of his money in Z and
part of it in X.
Well, he could end up here.
But why should he stop there?
Maybe he wants to take some
combination of the money that
was in Z and X and combine it
with some combination of things
that was in Z and Y,
combine this and this.
That would get him out to here.
So there are lots of different
combinations he could hold.
So graphically,
it looks like that.
Mathematically,
what's he trying to do?
He's trying to--so R now.
I've replaced A with R.
So R^(j) is just going to =
A^(j) divided by the price of j,
maybe times I.
So R^(j) will be the--let's
just say it's A^(j) divided by
pi_j.
So R^(j) is the return per
dollar you put in the asset.
R^(j) is the payoff of the
asset per dollar.
Let's stick with that.
Let's say the guy has a dollar
to spend, so it's the return per
dollar.
So those are all his
possibilities.
Now what does he want to do?
He wants to choose his money,
how much money he's going to
put in each asset,
which is omega_1
through omega_J.
That's the money he's going to
put in each asset.
And if he does that,
he's going to have a portfolio,
which I'll write as
R_omega,
so it's going to have a certain
expectation,
a certain variance.
So the question is,
how should he divide his money
between the assets,
and here's the kind of stuff he
could imagine doing.
Looks very complicated,
but it's going to turn out to
be very simple.
So are there any questions
about what we're doing so far?
I want to get a simple rule to
tell you, practical advice about
what to do.
Markowitz posed this problem.
This is the Markowitz problem,
okay?
It turns out,
by this argument,
you see if I keep combining
things over and over again,
I'm getting this sort of blob.
But the blob is always pushing
itself further and further out.
It's always convex,
because given any two points,
I can always do the thing to
the left of it.
So if I could do this and I
could do this,
and I look at the line
connecting them,
I can always be above that line
by spreading my money between
those two assets.
Or given this combination of
assets that produces this
expectation and standard
deviation,
and given that one up there,
I could combine the two and do
better than the straight line
connecting them,
do to the left of it.
So therefore,
all of the combinations put
together have to,
geometrically,
look like this in the end.
So I'm going to do this
algebraically in a second.
They have to look like that if
I did every possible variation.
It couldn't end up with a
picture where after I do every
possible variation--
if this is the expectation,
this is the standard deviation,
I couldn't get something that
looked like that,
because I would just combine
this thing with this thing.
Whatever portfolio produced
this, whatever portfolio
produced that,
I'd put half my money into each
of the stocks that this told me
to do,
half the money into each of the
stocks this told me to do.
I'd still end up investing 1
dollar and instead of getting
the line, I'd get something that
looked like that.
So I couldn't have the thing
going in like that.
It has to go out.
But then of course,
I can combine this and this and
get that, and so I'm going to
end up with this kind of shape.
Now I'm going to prove that
algebraically.
But if I had that kind of
shape, then what would the guy
do?
He'd choose something like
that, where he's tangent.
That's what Markowitz basically
did, except he did it
algebraically.
So that's what Markowitz did.
That doesn't seem to have
gotten us very far.
You notice that different
people are going to make
different choices.
If somebody is incredibly
worried--someone's not very
worried about the standard
deviation and cares a lot about
expectation,
they're going to have a flatter
indifference curve.
So instead of looking like
that, it will be a flatter
thing.
And so if it's flatter,
the guy who cares--
sorry, if it's flatter,
it means he cares about
expectation and not standard
deviation,
because a little bit of
expectation can compensate him
for a lot more standard
deviation,
so his indifference curve is
flatter.
He's going to choose further up.
So he's going to choose a point
like way up there.
So he's going to get a higher
expectation and higher standard
deviation.
Someone who's more risk averse
is going to choose where that
point is.
So that's qualitatively what's
going on.
So Markowitz played around with
this, played around with this.
Then Tobin appears on the scene.
Tobin says, "All this gets
so much easier if you have a
riskless asset."
Let's suppose that there's a
bond.
You haven't mentioned the bond
yet.
Let's suppose we have a bond
that pays something for sure,
and we're going to ignore
inflation, Tobin said,
which is a big problem.
We should come back to that if
we have time.
We're going to ignore
inflation, so US Treasury's
going to pay a certain amount of
money for sure.
So it has an expectation like
this, but no standard deviation.
It's 0.
Now why is this so important?
Let's imagine combining this
riskless bond with some other
stock X, 1 dollar's worth of X.
1 dollar's worth of the
riskless bond gets you 1.06 say.
1 dollar's worth of X gets you
much--you know,
maybe your average is 1.12,
but you're also running a big
risk.
What happens if you put your
money part way in between them?
So suppose you put part of your
money in X, and the rest of your
money in the riskless bond.
What's your expectation going
to be?
Your expectation,
let's say X is 12 percent and Y
is 6 percent,
1.06 and 1.12,
the average is going to be 1.09
if you put half your money in
both.
But what is the standard
deviation going to be?
I claim it's just going to be
on this straight line.
Why is that?
Because the riskless thing has
covariance 0.
If X is riskless,
its covariance is going to be 0
with Y.
So these terms are going to
disappear.
Look at the covariance.
If X--ifY is the riskless bond,
it pays always its expectation.
So these numbers are always 0.
Therefore the covariance of
that thing with anything,
the covariance of Y with any X
is going to be 0.
And not only that,
but the variance of Y itself is
also 0.
So all you get is,
for the variance of the t
dollars in X and 1 - t dollars
in Y, you just get t squared
times the variance of X.
But then when you take the
standard deviation,
it's just t times the standard
deviation of X.
So in other words,
the standard deviation of the
mixture of Y and X lies right on
the line.
So unlike--to put it another
way, something that has no
variance is perfectly correlated
with everything else,
it makes no difference.
When the other thing goes up or
down, it doesn't tell you--you
still know what Y's going to be.
So unlike everything else,
where you have this bow shaped
thing, the riskless asset just
connects everything to a
straight line.
So if there were a riskless
asset and you could do this with
some X and here was a Z,
you could also do that,
or you could do that.
Is this clear?
Okay, so the punch line,
which we're now going to see
algebraically,
the punch line is--and by the
way, if I combine,
what does it mean to extend
that line?
I should have extended that
line.
That was a huge mistake.
Suppose instead of--so here's
all the money in the riskless
asset.
Here's half the money in the
riskless asset and half in X.
Here's all my money in X.
What would happen if I extended
the line here?
What would that correspond to?
I'm now at a point on the
extension of the line.
How do I get that?
Student:
You borrow money and invest it
in X.
Prof: Right.
That's negative Y and bigger
than 1 in X.
So negative 1 half of X 1 and 1
half of Y, that's still 1
dollar.
I sold X short and so I'm just
going to continue the line that
way.
So I shouldn't have stopped
here.
I could have kept going.
So it's putting money in the
bank and sharing it between a
single stock puts me on this
line.
Borrowing money from the bank
to put in a stock is called
leveraging my return,
puts me on the extension of the
line.
We're going to come back to
that in a second.
So knowing that,
now what should I do?
Is there something really
simple?
Well, what would you do here,
faced with this choice?
Which combination of stocks and
bonds would you hold?
I say it's really simple.
You just look for a line
through the riskless point
that's tangent to this blurb,
which happens to be here,
and now you should choose your
point anywhere along this line,
independent of what your
mean-variance utilities are.
No matter how risk averse you
are or how risk loving you are,
you should choose somewhere
along this line.
Why is that?
Well, I've drawn,
with this blob,
I've drawn all the possible
combinations I could get by
mixing different risky assets.
What I left out of the picture
is all the combinations I could
get by adding the riskless
asset.
I've got all the risky asset
combinations.
That's the blob.
Now I want to do--adding the
riskless asset means I can take
part of my money in here and
part in there.
So in particular,
I can put part of my money here
and part of my money there,
or I can go short.
So whatever this combination
was, that's the best thing I can
do, because now I can get
everything along this line.
Nothing else can do better.
What other combination could
there be?
It has to be the riskless asset
a bunch of risky assets.
But combining the risky assets
just puts me in the blob.
So it might put me here in the
blob.
And then once I combine that
with the riskless asset,
I'll be on that line.
This line is always below that
line, so this is the best
possible thing I can do.
No combination of the riskless
asset and any other combination
of risky assets,
that'll always put me on some
line from here,
through some point in the blob,
which is going to be below this
tangent point.
So this is the best thing I can
do.
And it's independent of whether
I was risk averse or a risk
lover.
If I'm risk averse and want to
play it safe,
my utility function--I forgot
what those looked like.
My indifference curves--I'll be
here.
I'll put most of my money in
the bank and not very many in
the risky stock.
If I'm more of a risk lover,
I'll be maybe here,
and I'll choose to put a good
fraction of my money in the
stock and only a little in the
bank.
If I'm really reckless,
I'll borrow money and put it in
the stock market and be way up
there.
But everybody will do the same
thing, no matter what their
preferences are.
They'll all be along the same
line.
So that's the mutual fund
theorem.
Why is that the mutual fund
theorem?
Because it says everybody
should invest in the same index
of stocks and put more or less
money in the bank.
So every single person ought to
be doing the same thing.
This is the mutual fund that
everybody should hold.
Whatever combination of stocks
that got me to this point is the
mutual fund that everybody
should hold,
and combine that with putting
money in the bank.
Okay, so let's just prove that
algebraically,
in a special case,
which is going to illustrate
the point, the idea of it
anyway.
I'm doing a very special case
here, but just to illustrate it
algebraically.
So suppose that the Rs are,
as we said, the returns,
up here, per dollar of stock.
The R_0 I've now
added and that's going to be the
riskless asset that pays like 1
dollar 6 all the time,
if the interest rate is 6
percent.
So now you have your money,
you have I dollars.
You're the investor with I
dollars.
You can divide that money into
the riskless asset or any one of
the J assets.
So here you've got R^(0).
You can get that return,
R^(1) up to R^(J) and you can
put money,
omega_0,
omega_1,
omega_J,
but of course,
this all has to add up to I.
So how should you do it?
Well, you care about your
expectation and you hate
variance, so I'm doing just a
special case to make it
illustrate the idea.
Suppose I write down your
utility as if it were the
expectation, - alpha times the
variance.
It could be a more complicated
function.
We said already that the
quadratic utilities give you
expectation - alpha expectation
squared, - some other alpha
times the variance.
That's the utility we derive
from quadratic--
when people have quadratic
utilities over consumption,
their induced utility of
portfolios is this thing.
So it's not exactly the one
I've written down,
but the argument would be just
the same and this is shorter and
simpler.
So just to illustrate the
flavor of it,
let's say all you care about is
your expectation - some
constant, how risk averse you
are, times the variance.
Now let's suppose,
to keep it even simpler,
that the assets are all
independent.
The theory doesn't rely on that.
I'm just saying,
suppose it were so we can
algebraically get it without
having to work very hard.
So you're maximizing your
expectations,
so the bar above means the
expectation.
So what's your expectation of
omega dollars in here,
omega_1 in here and
omega_J in here?
Just omega_0 times
the expectation of this.
So your expectation then is
going to be omega_0
times R^(0) bar (that's the
expectation of that)
omega_1,
R bar^(1) omega_J,
R bar^(J).
These are the top for some
reason.
That's your expectation.
Now what's your variance,
the thing that you don't like?
Your variance is going to
be--is going to be the variance
of these.
They're independent.
So the variance is just going
to be what I've written.
So call the variance of R^(J)
sigma,
so it's going to be
sigma_0 squared
(that's the variance of
sigma_0) times
omega_0 squared,
(remember, because for variance
you have to square if you
multiply by something)
omega_1 squared
sigma_1 squared,
omega_J squared
sigma_J squared.
Now of course,
remember that the variance of
the riskless thing is 0,
so that's actually 0.
This is the variance you have
to watch out for.
This is the expectation you
want.
How should you pick
omega_0,
omega_1,
omega_J,
when your penalty for having
too much variance is alpha?
So different investors have
different risk aversions so they
have different alphas.
Should they be led,
as Markowitz thought,
without the riskless asset,
remember,
with the blob like this,
one guy was going to pick here,
another guy was going to pick
there.
They'd all do very different
things.
Tobin added this riskless
asset, and lo and behold,
now everyone should do the same
thing.
So why is that?
We just reduce this
algebraically,
solve it algebraically.
So the constraint is a nuisance.
To maximize something with the
constraint's a nuisance,
so if you just notice that if
you satisfy the constraint,
omega_0 has to equal
I - the sum of the
omega_js.
So if I substitute for
omega_0 right up
there, I substitute I - the sum
of the js.
Then I'm going to get R bar^(0)
times I - R bar^(0) times
omega_1,
- R bar^(0) times
omega_2.
But I can feed that into the
other thing,
so I get R^(0) times the I,
and then the R^(1) term is
going to be R bar^(1) times
omega_1 - the thing
that came from subtracting the
omega_1 there in I--
by replacing omega_0
with (I - omega_1 -
omega_J),
etc.
So I'm going to notice--all
these other terms now,
I get rid of the constraint and
all the other terms get
replaced.
R bar^(2) gets replaced by R
bar^(2) - R bar^(0).
I've dropped sigma_0
because it's 0.
So I'm maximizing something
without a constraint by plugging
in the constraint to
omega_0.
So I have to choose my
omega_1 through
omega_J and then
omega_0 is determined
from that.
But I'm maximizing one thing,
so just take the derivative
with respect to each
omega_i and set it =
to 0.
So with respect to
omega_1,
say, it's going to be R bar^(1)
- R bar^(0) - 2 alpha sigma--
I'm differentiating with
respect to omega_1 so
it's 2 alpha omega_1
times sigma_1 squared.
2 alpha omega_1 times
sigma_1 squared = 0.
So therefore omega_1
= R^(1) - R^(0) over 2 alpha
sigma_1 squared.
But if I did it now with
respect to 2 or to 3 or to 4,
nothing--I would get the same
formula, just with a j instead
of a 1.
So that's the formula everybody
picks and notice it depends on
what alpha is.
So people with different alphas
are going to put different
amounts of money in
omega_j.
But it depends on alpha in a
very trivial way.
So if I took the fraction,
the relative amounts of money I
put in i and j and divided this
by omega_i,
by omega_j,
I would get that the alphas and
the 2s canceled out.
So everybody would put R^(i) -
R bar^(0) divided by
sigma_i squared,
R bar^(j) - R^(0) over
sigma_j squared.
That number doesn't depend on
who the person is,
so the relative amounts of
money put in i and j are
independent of what your alpha
is,
independent of the person.
So unlike this old Markowitz
case,
the Tobin case looks like that,
and everybody chooses the same
combination of risky assets and
then this safe asset.
So it may be that different
people put different
combinations of safe and risky,
but everybody's proportion of
risky assets is proportional to
everybody else's.
That's what we just proved
algebraically.
So graphically,
a sort of general proof,
algebraically,
a special case.
And then if you were in a
graduate class,
you'd get an algebraic proof in
general,
which is actually much faster
than either of these,
but you have to know a little
linear algebra.
And so that's the proof.
It's a very simple thing.
It's a remarkable thing,
and here's the famous Tobin
diagram.
Everybody should do that,
put their money in the same
combination of risky assets and
the riskless asset.
Are there any questions about
this?
It's kind of shocking.
I could swear that most people
think, maybe even rightly,
if you really want to go for
it, put your money in the young
Microsoft or something.
It could be a tremendous
success or it could go out of
business.
That's what you should do,
but no, this says not at all.
If you really want to go for
it, take the same index that
everybody, the S&P 500 and
just leverage it.
Borrow a lot of money and go
out that straight line,
way out to there,
to the right.
Don't put your money in
Microsoft.
Just leverage the hell out of
the S&P 500.
Okay, so after this theory was
created--I'm going to tease out
all the implications of it.
After this theory was created,
the mutual fund business took
off.
Vanguard and all of these
places, what did they do?
They said, "Look,
economic science has taught us,
the best you can do is not try
to pick individual stocks.
The best you can do is to hold
the same index,
the whole market.
"Now of course,
it's very expensive for you to
hold the whole market.
Are you going to go to a broker
and tell him 'Buy me 3 shares of
this and 7 shares of that and 9
shares of that,
14 shares of that'?
It'll take the guy forever to
buy all that stuff and you have
to pay a commission on every
single thing you buy.
It's going to cost you so much
money to do what economic
science says.
Come to us at Vanguard.
We'll buy the whole market for
you,
call it our index fund and
charge you almost no commission
at all,
just a tiny little bit,
because we're doing it in such
bulk,
everyone's--we've got lots of
investors like you.
They're all buying the same
thing.
We have huge volume,
so we're going to get a really
small brokerage fee,
so you should put your money in
with us."
So that's what everybody
started to do.
So all these mutual funds and
money managers,
they all grew up,
originally by guaranteeing to
produce an index fund,
the very same thing economic
science recommended,
at almost no cost.
If you read Swensen's book,
his first,
most important piece of advice:
if you are a standard investor
who doesn't know how to
manipulate all the complicated
instruments on Wall Street and
has transactions costs and
things like that,
put all your money into an
index.
That's what he recommends doing.
And he says everyone else who
tells you otherwise is just
trying to steal your money,
rip you off.
So that's the main financial
advice that economists give now.
It's Shakespeare's advice.
Don't put all your eggs in one
basket, but it's very specific.
Put it in an index where you
buy everything in the same
proportion.
Now of course,
if you're buying everything in
the same proportion and
everybody's doing that,
what does this have to be?
I forgot to say that.
If everybody's buying every
stock in the same proportion,
that proportion must be the
market, because that's what
everybody's holding.
So this doesn't turn out to be
any old portfolio.
It's the market portfolio.
So the index,
that's a huge conclusion here,
the index that they should
offer is not just some magical
index that's better than
everything else,
because if everyone's doing the
right thing,
everyone's choosing the same
index--
that's what we proved--if
everyone's choosing the same
index,
it must be the market index,
because that's all there is to
choose.
Supply has to equal demand.
So therefore the advice is to
put all your money into the
market index,
not just an index,
the market index maybe put
money in a bank.
Or even borrow from a bank to
put it into the market index.
That's the first surprising
theorem that Tobin proved and it
had dramatic--so it created the
indexed investments.
It created Vanguard.
So these people who run these
companies, I forgot the guy's
name who runs Vanguard.
He's always giving these
speeches.
So that's how he describes how
he got his start in his
business.
All he says is,
"I take all the
recommendations of economic
science,"
he says,
"and I allow people to
carry them out.
That's why I'm doing great good
for society.
Everybody else,
all these hedge funds and
stuff, they're ruining society.
I am just doing what Tobin told
us to do."
That's his basic speech.
So Markowitz was a little bit
more precise even than that.
Markowitz' formula and Tobin's
special case,
he not only told you what to
do.
He told you,
"do what everyone else is
doing."
He told you what that should be.
So let's suppose that I've got
2 stocks,
i and j, with the same return,
same expected return,
but one has standard deviation
3 times higher than the other.
So in my picture here,
that standard picture,
we've got the standard
deviation, we've got the
expectation.
We've got 1 stock here and
we've got another stock here
with 3 times the standard
deviation.
So you might have thought,
"Well, these 2 stocks,
same expected return,
what's the difference?
Put all my money in one or the
other, doesn't matter."
A little bit further thought
would say, "Well,
this one is much better than
that one.
I've got smaller standard
deviation, so I should put all
my money into this one."
But then on further thought,
given that these two are
independent, what should you do?
How should you allocate your
money between this stock and
that stock?
What does the formula tell you
to do?
It's very clear.
Well, the ratio of money in one
stock to the other stock looks
like this ratio.
But I've told you that the
expectations of the 2 stocks are
the same.
So those things are the same.
I've told you that one has 3
times the standard deviation
than the other,
so therefore,
what should you do?
Yeah.
Student:
Hold 9 times as much as the one
with the lower--
Prof: Exactly.
You should put 90 percent in
this stock, 10 percent in that
stock.
That's it, because if one
sigma's 3 times the other,
and you square it,
it's going to be 9 times the
other,
and so obviously you have to
figure out what's in the
numerator and what's in the
denominator.
But clearly,
you're going to put more of
your money in the lower standard
deviation, so it's 90/10.
So it's very concrete advice.
So the first concrete advice
is, the first concrete thing
we've gotten out of this is,
buy the index.
Now the index typically in
America, they're easy to buy,
are indexes of stocks.
But you know,
the second piece of advice is,
and this is also Swensen's
second most important point--
I'm quoting Swensen because
we're here at Yale,
not because he's the only one
to recognize these things,
but he was a student of
Tobin--so the second important
point is that you should not
just buy the index,
because the indexes are the
wrong index.
The index should be the index
of everything.
It should include American
stocks, Chinese stocks,
French stocks,
Greek stocks,
Israeli stocks.
You should have all stocks in
the index, but you can't really
very easily buy all those other
things.
You can only very easily buy
index of American things.
It's getting easier and easier
now to buy the global index.
But anyway, you should buy the
global index.
That's what this says.
So every time you find a new
independent risk you should look
for it.
So you should buy the global
index, seek out independent
risks.
So what did Swensen do?
One of his most important
things was, Yale is always
looking globally to find
independent risks.
So let's go back to the--so you
should always find independent
risks, and you suffer if you
don't.
So you see, by putting 90
percent here and 10 percent
here, Markowitz is telling you,
you're going to do better.
What else do I have to say?
So let's go back to our dice
example.
Suppose that you had 1 dice.
Now by the way,
I want to introduce one more
term, which I'll call the Sharpe
ratio.
So the slope of this line--so
it's the Tobin diagram.
It should be called the Tobin
ratio, but this other guy at
Stanford snuck in and managed to
give his name to it.
He ended up getting a Nobel
prize too.
So here this line,
the slope of this line,
this is the riskless asset--the
slope of this line,
what is the slope of this line?
So this is standard deviation,
this is expectation.
The slope, what's the slope?
Well, it's the expectation of
whatever you're holding,
X, - the riskless asset divided
by the standard deviation of X.
That's the Sharpe ratio of X.
So you notice that every point
you could conceivably choose,
which is somewhere in this
blob, then connect it to the
riskless asset--
so every point on this line
obviously has the same Sharpe
ratio.
If you leveraged your position
and went to here,
you wouldn't change your Sharpe
ratio.
It has the same slope.
If you put half your money in
the bank and half in the
riskless asset,
you'd be here,
same Sharpe ratio.
Anything else you could do has
a lower Sharpe ratio.
So another thing to say is that
an investor managing all his
money should maximize the Sharpe
ratio.
You could in fact tell if
somebody had screwed up.
Instead of doing the global
index, they just did the
American index,
pick something here,
you could look at the slope of
where they ended up and it would
be a worse slope and a worse
Sharpe ratio.
You could even judge people,
how they're doing,
by looking at their Sharpe
ratio.
So let's take the case of the 2
dice.
Suppose you had 1 die.
So if you had 1 die,
remember, if you invest 100
dollars, you could get 101,102,
through 106.
Let's say the interest rate is
3 percent.
So you could get 101,102,
103,104, 105,106,
with 1 sixth probability of
each.
So the average of that is
obviously 103.5,
right, because 1 and 6 is 7,
and divide by 2,
is 103.5.
So the expected payoff for
putting your money into 1 dice
is the average return,
is 1.035.
The riskless return is going to
be 1.03, so it's .035 - .03,
.005.
And now what's the standard
deviation?
What's the variance of this?
Well, you could take 101 -
103.5 squared,
103 - 103.5 squared,
etc.
and take the square root of it,
and you'd get .017.
So you notice the chance of
losing money,
by the way, is 50 percent.
50 percent of the time,
you're going to lose money,
and your Sharpe ratio is .005
over .017.
So that's about 3--no,
it's about .3.
Now that happens to be the
Sharpe ratio of the stock
market, just about.
Shockingly low,
isn't it, if you look at the
history of the stock market--
so it depends what year you
start and what year you end,
if you do it right after a
crash or before a crash,
but just to pick vague numbers
it's 9 percent and let's say the
interest rate is 4 percent,
something like that.
It could be 5 percent or 3
percent.
Depends again the period.
Maybe it's 2 percent,
but somewhere like that.
And the standard deviation of
the stock market is 16 percent
or 12 percent,
again depending on what period.
But always around 12 to 18
percent, let's say 16 percent.
That's the one I like to use,
because it's percent a day.
So that's = to 5 percent over
16 percent, which is about 1
third.
It's about .3.
That's exactly what this dice
has, about .3.
So that's all you can get out
of the stock market.
Not a very good Sharpe ratio.
So you could measure Swensen's
Sharpe ratio.
You could measure Ellington's
Sharpe ratio and see what they
are.
You can see who you think is a
better manager.
So I won't tell you those
numbers just yet.
But now let's suppose,
what else could I do?
So let's suppose you put your
money in two dice.
That's the whole point of this.
Suppose you put half your money
in the first dice and half your
money in the second die.
Now what are the
chances--what's going to happen?
Well, again,
your expected return hasn't
changed.
It's still .035,
but the Sharpe ratio has
drastically changed.
In fact, you could see that.
What are the chances of ending
up with 101 dollars now,
if you put half your money in
each, the worst case?
It's not 1 in 6.
You have to get the worst case
in both dice.
So to get 101 dollars,
it's 1 in 36.
It's vastly less likely that
you end up with this extreme bad
outcome once you put half the
money in each die.
So if you compute the standard
deviation, it's going to be a
lot smaller number.
It's going to be .012.
So the Sharpe ratio's gone from
.3 to .4, just by finding the
second die.
So what you should be doing is
looking,
like Swensen does,
like everybody does,
for those independent risks
that the rest of the market is
too stupid to see.
Even after they got the idea of
the index, for 20 years,
they didn't realize the index
should mean everything,
not just in America.
So you'd have a huge
opportunity to do better than
the rest of the managers.
While everyone else is screwing
around on this line,
you can be screwing around on
that line.
So you could run the same risk
this guy did.
So Swensen says,
you could leverage--
not that he does,
but if you're Harvard and
you're on this thing instead of
this thing,
you could leverage and go up
here and say,
"Look, I've got the same
standard deviation everybody
else does,
and look at my returns.
They're so much higher than
everybody else's."
So that's what Harvard is
trying to do.
They're trying to globally
diversify,
cut down their standard
deviation and then leverage,
and compared to everybody else,
get a higher return with the
same standard deviation.
So that's the first implication
of the theory.
Now the second implication is
the best part.
Let's hope I get to it.
I'm going to skip over leverage.
The second story is coming
right up.
How are these things priced?
I have to get to the second
part of Shakespeare.
What can we say about the
pricing of individual stocks?
It looks like an individual
stock is going to be worth more
if it contributes no variance,
less variance.
But that turns out to be
completely wrong.
It's shocking that that's wrong.
So why is this?
The crucial thing is,
remember back to our first
principles.
What is price = to?
What is the key ingredient of
price?
What is it always = to in basic
economics?
Student:
Supply and demand.
Prof: Supply and demand,
okay.
But an individual's going to
buy so that price is = to his
marginal utility,
right?
So we have to figure out--what
we've shown so far is that
everybody is holding the market.
Everybody's holding a market,
maybe with some riskless asset.
So they're holding the market,
plus maybe they're long or
short the bonds,
but that's not creating any
covariance.
So if I'm holding the market
and I hold a little bit more of
a stock,
so if I could pay a little bit
more and buy t units of stock X,
what good would it do me?
Well, the expectation,
the change in expectation,
with t dollars of X would be,
as I increase t a little bit,
the derivative of my
expectation is just the
expectation of X.
So by holding the new stock,
I get expectation of--I get a
little more.
I get t times the expectation
of X, I hope.
By coming up with t extra
dollars, I could increase my
expectation by t times the
expectation of X obviously.
But what would happen to my
variance?
If I look at the variance of
this, what happens to my
variance?
Which is = (for variance I
could write) is the covariance
of this with itself,
tX M.
So everybody's supposed to hold
M some riskless thing,
negative or positive in the
bond.
But the negative or positive in
the bond is riskless asset.
That contributes nothing to the
covariance.
I might as well just look at
the covariance of a little bit
of money in X with the market.
And what's that covariance
going to be?
Well, it's covariance of t,
tX and,
tX, covariance of tX and M
(these are definitely not 0
anymore) covariance of--
so it's 2,2t,
covariance of tX and M.
And then it's the,
covariance of M with itself.
So it's the covariance of tX
with itself,
tX with tX, twice the
covariance of tX with M and then
this tX with M,
2 covariance tX with M,
and the covariance of M with
itself.
Now I want to differentiate
that thing with respect to t.
If I put just a little bit of
money, that's being on the
margin, what's the marginal
effect on my variance?
I hate variance,
but see the mistake people have
made in the past is they said,
"People hate variance.
Therefore a stock that has a
lot of variance is bad."
Absolutely wrong reasoning.
That was Adam Smith's puzzle
about water and diamonds.
You know, why is water less
expensive than diamonds when
water's so much more important?
It's not how important the
whole thing is;
it's how important one tiny
extra drop of it is,
the marginal utility.
So if you add a tiny bit of X
to what you're already holding,
which might involve a bunch of
X already,
so you add a tiny bit more of X
to what you're already holding,
what's going to be the change
in your variance?
So it's the derivative of this
with respect to t,
when t = 0.
So this, by the way,
= t squared,
variance of X 2 covariance--2t
times the covariance of X and M
the variance of M.
I'm differentiating this with
respect to t.
Right?
Because I've just rewritten the
same thing.
That's just t squared,
the variance of X.
The t comes out,
2t covariance of X with M,
and here's the variance of M.
But if I differentiate with
respect to t,
I get 2t variance of X
(remember, it's the derivative
of t when t is 0),
2t variance of X 2 covariance
of X and M 0,
because the variance of M
doesn't depend on t.
So at t = 0, this is also 0.
So you see the change in my
variance, when I add a little
more of X, is twice the
covariance of X and M.
So what is it that X adds?
It adds some expectation and it
also adds some variance,
but not according to the
variance of X,
according to the covariance of
X with M.
When I add some more--the price
of water is how much extra
utility I get,
given what I've already got.
I've already got a huge amount
of water.
That's why an extra amount of
water's not doing much for me.
That's why the price is low.
So X itself might be very
dangerous,
but if it's independent of all
the other stuff,
M, that you're holding,
in fact, you're only adding a
drop of it,
it won't change your variance
hardly at all.
So this is 0.
It's the covariance.
So that's the crucial idea,
that the marginal contribution
of every stock depends on its
expectation and its covariance,
not its variance.
And the expectation is good and
the covariance is bad.
And all of this is linear,
because it's differentiable,
so it just says that--this is
the change in covariance.
So remember the guy,
the marginal utility of
expectation.
How am I doing in time?
1 more minute.
Marginal utility of expectation
times the expectation of X,
that's the change,
when you add 1 dollar's worth--
a tiny bit of X,
your expectation goes up by the
expectation of X.
So this is the marginal utility
of expectation,
which is the good thing,
- the marginal utility of
variance.
That's the bad thing.
And what's the change?
The thing that affects--the
contribution to variance is the
covariance of X with M.
So the punch line is,
everybody has a linear tradeoff
between expectation and
covariance.
So for any fixed person,
it's just a constant times the
expectation of X - a constant
times--this doesn't depend on
the portfolio.
This is the marginal utility at
his consumption.
Marginal utility of expectation
at his consumption.
You face him with any possible
new thing that he could buy,
just like a consumer in the
first day of class.
He could buy apples,
he could buy oranges,
he could buy pears.
The marginal utility of each
one of those at the point he's
already chosen to consume.
This is a number that's fixed,
this is a number that's fixed.
Whatever X I put in here,
that's what I get.
So there's a linear tradeoff
between expectation and
covariance.
Expectation good,
covariance bad.
So the final picture is that in
equilibrium, what you should
have is every stock--this is
called the security market line.
This is the expectation of X.
This is the covariance of X
with M.
So what we've found is that it
should look like this.
There has to be a linear
relationship.
In order to want the stock--if
it's got a higher covariance,
that means it's adding bad
stuff.
You wouldn't want it unless it
had a higher expectation.
So here's the riskless asset
right here.
So this is a different diagram
than the Tobin diagram.
It's expectation and covariance.
Every stock is along this line.
Should be priced along this
line.
So let me end with a puzzle,
the one we started with on the
first day of class.
If I have two companies,
General Motors and AIDS--an
anti AIDS company.
Some scientist at Yale
discovers a cure for AIDS.
He calls it AIDS.
He discovers a cure for AIDS.
If the thing works,
he'll make a fortune.
If the thing doesn't work,
of course, it's going to go
bankrupt and pay anyone no
money.
Let's say we calculate the
expected profits of General
Electric.
General Motors is too junky now.
General Electric.
Let's say the expected profits
of General Electric = the
expected profits of the
anti-AIDS company.
Which will sell for a higher
price?
Student:
General Electric.
Prof: Will sell for a
higher price.
Why?
Student:
>
the variability of the outcome.
Prof: Okay,
that's what you should have
said at the beginning of class,
but not at the end of class.
Who's saying that?
Down here.
Who said that?
Who just said that?
I don't want to embarrass
anyone.
All right, you're anonymous.
I didn't see who it was,
so exactly.
That's what you would have
thought before this class began.
Everybody hates variance.
The AIDS company is so risky,
you could get a fortune or 0.
You couldn't get riskier than
that.
General Electric is not going
to go bankrupt very easily and
it's not going to suddenly
multiply its value by 100 times
either.
It's much more solid.
So which would you pay more for?
Everyone at the beginning of
the class,
I think, would have said like
he did,
whoever he is,
would have said "General
Electric,
you'd pay more for."
But the answer's not General
Electric.
Why is that?
Yes?
Student:
Because the cure for AIDS
actually working is uncorrelated
with the state of the economy,
>
Prof: Exactly.
That's the shocking fact.
That's the shocking conclusion.
So Shakespeare,
yes, "Nothing ventured,
nothing gained."
You have to take a risk to
expect a higher return.
Everyone would have thought
that's the anti-AIDS company.
No it's not,
and Shakespeare couldn't
possibly have figured this out.
It's General Electric is the
one with the higher risk,
because it's correlated with
the market.
It's correlated with the market.
Obviously if people are rich,
they're going to buy more
refrigerators and engines and
stuff like that.
If business isn't doing very
well, they're not going to buy
that stuff.
It's very correlated with the
market.
Anti-AIDS, if it cures AIDS,
people are going to buy it.
If they've got AIDS,
they're going to buy it no
matter what, otherwise they
won't, so it's uncorrelated with
the market.
So therefore the price of the
AIDS company is going to be its
expected payoff,
discounted.
The price of General Motors
[correction: General Electric]
is going to be much less,
because it's going to be
punished for having a
correlation with the market.
Therefore the return on General
Electric is going to be much
higher,
because the same expected
payoff and a lower price,
your return's going to be
higher in General Electric.
That's the shocking thing that
Shakespeare couldn't have
noticed.
So yes, we're just doing what
Shakespeare said in the
beginning, but in a way he
couldn't possibly have done
without any mathematics.
Okay, now the problem set,
you'll have to see if you can
do the problem set.
It's due on Tuesday.